je vous raconte je racontais à briques à
un jour ça me rappelle quelque chose que
la fesse l'a fait sien un endroit très
très sensible je vous jure t réer ou et
j'étais donc animateur dans un club de
vacances à une époque
et j avais fait un sketch sur à ce que
vous vous rappelez de la pub mais rios
ont le mérite de ne pas tolérer
d'ailleurs en beauté et donc je faisais
le rideau qui marchaient sur le mur est
bien le truc est donc j'ai dit voilà je
vais refaire je me mets des pubs et j'ai
aimé un matelas et donc je monte dans le
truc se montaient une échelle de sauter
gens venaient là et un moment j'ai raté
le matelas en retombant je suis tombé
sur la fesse et j'ai passé toutes les
vacances avec une fesse plus grosse que
los de nadau
mais je voyais en mai des fous rires et
ses dérivés sepa sepa du lido et j'avais
et toutes les matières et gt gt prof de
tennis donc imaginer toutes les vacances
j'étais comme ça donc en fait avec la
fesse énorme dans le short et ça c'est
voilà donc et donc je connais ce que
c'est un grosse j'ai fait ma j'ai déjà
eu très très mal aux fesses gilles
bertrand
[Applaudissements]